the Joe Rogan experience the course is
getting bad without weed money the weed
money and now mushroom money cuz now
Denver decriminalized mushrooms
prostitution next boo probably cheaper
ten days excited a man
la boy stuff I don't I don't know I
probably to spend a lot of money on
first dates
yeah I'm sure realistic because it sucks
to be a man in dating because you got to
impress well if you impress it does
listen when before I started making
money and having money dating was fun
cuz she was broke and you can do
smoothly dates and Starbucks dates and
you know you're gonna spend five six
bucks out of college now I'm 37
yeah it's you're too close to forty to
be doing that I know you can't do that
anymore you got you got to take chicks
to Palm Springs for the weekend things
like that well they want to know I like
that stuff now though sure to a nice
dinner by I'm nice
don't fall any woman that wants a man
that has a [ __ ] together yeah because
for so long I didn't right now I do now
I want to have some fun of course yeah
forget that I ain't trying to complain
no more but as far as like cities of the
vibe I love the vibe of San Diego and I
love the vibe of Denver I love those
cities yeah I'm leaning towards back to
San Diego because it's still close to
like I just drove to Irvine other day I
was like that was a simple job yeah as
long as you do it early yeah he tried to
do that [ __ ] at four o'clock in the
afternoon you want to shoot yeah you
will want to do Irvine improv I work out
all the time dude when I have a seven
o'clock show I leave here at [ __ ]
noon and I'm not playing games I leave
here at noon I get there early
I check in I have dinner I don't [ __ ]
around with that 4 p.m. traffic it's
insane nuts it took me six hours to get
down there once when you went to shop
show when he had his special how early
do no no no damn got a hotel just to put
my [ __ ] in checked in checked out I
didn't even stay there my daughter had
an event the next day that I had to go
to for school so I was over I said yeah
I drove that back that night after the
show after the second show that's a
that's an easy drop though I'm it's not
bad yeah especially late late at night
yeah you get a couple Red Bulls in you
yeah I got to LA quick once
from when I lived in San Diego I'll use
my boys truck I met this girl online in
the middle of the night and just drove
girl on why in the middle I know if I
ever was going end up on the Joe Rogan
podcast I thought it was gonna be for me
writing a book about online dating
confessions of an online dater I swear I
let you do that
Maxim you don't need a book but just do
a video about it do documentaries about
how crazy I used to film girls and
interview him and everything about
dating like what sucks about dating and
things like that online dating is only
existed for like like edits mmm
roars form 20 years right Ross form was
20 years ago that was like AOL that was
you use a weirdo danda oh wow now
everybody listen if you if you do tinder
or bumble in LA you see in celebrities
and everything on it yes chicks like all
these successful chicks on searching for
love
that's scary Justin why is it scary
because you don't know who you really
meet him like for a woman imagine me in
a woman yeah yeah I was it was sucked to
be a woman that's not gonna be weird a
successful celebrity woman trying to
meet dudes you want to hear this story
and this is crazy so I met this famous
online female trainer beautiful here in
LA she's very popular I'm gonna say her
name
I met her on match.com and I got her
Instagram and she we you know exchanged
our instagrams or whatever so I read I
looked at it looked at her or her
Instagram and she was doing like you
know content but on her phone like in
her living room doing like squat jumps
and things like that and I reached out
to her like we set up a date we gonna go
hike and run you and do everything and I
was like listen I I looked at your your
your your Instagram page in your content
I would love to be able to help you out
and give you better content she lost it
I don't need your help I don't need your
help you look like you need to help
yourself like I'm like I'm just telling
you that I could help I'm like why like
I am a filmmaker I could help you do
some content like she thinking she took
it the wrong way like I'm probably
trying to take advantage of her
millions of followers and things like
that I was like man I'm gonna be single
forever but I think sometimes that's
also there's a very limited
communicating with people on in a text
yeah did you take it the wrong way yeah
yeah yeah you gotta kind of meet people
like if you but I bet if you met her and
you said hey you know you're you are
beautiful you got a great body these
videos are great and everything but I
think I could make them even better she
still would have took it the wrong way
oh she was like in her 40 40s alpha
female
you know those alpha females that you
can't some girls have been [ __ ] over
so many times they think everyone's
gonna [ __ ] them over it's like a dog's
butt beatin you ever pick up a dog from
the pound oh yeah yeah you're like hey I
love dogs come on I'm not gonna beat you
there
[Applause]